you were at can this is right yes there
was a gun Film Festival hon I'm sorry
cotton June festival gun Film Festival
and this is for a were you premiering a
film there oh absolutely not I'm
carrying a slide whistle did you get him
to go to Cana I was Sony said Sony
animation said it do you want to do this
publicity stunt where you would
essentially in a yellow tuxedo Paris
sail into gun film festival and
premiered the emoji movie trailer and I
said yes now wait so was this safe and
what you're going to parasail in right
yeah you planned with a giant parachute
that's is yellow and said the emoji
movie it's just like the biggest middle
finger emoji to confirm festival yeah
because they're so pretentious they
don't women need to wear high heels and
there's this been this whole thing right
so it seemed like the perfect thing to
do and did it go smoothly I mean do the
clip I think they brought a clip I
haven't seen it yet I guess shall we
find out
my guess is it
the low-key emoji movie to do a stunt
that shows how exciting adventurous is
gonna be the absolute absurdity of that
was so perfect for us to be there for me
to be there for that and it was very
confusing to people because big stars
show up at that yeah your doppelganger
was there my doppelganger who we talking
about Tilda Swinton Oh Tilda Swinton I
think we have a photo here yeah I think
I do woman and she is your a better hair
but we we met her and it was this moment
she's so uh she really is like a living
breathing unicorn and Cate my wife was
in you know the decked out in these
gowns and really nervous and she stepped
on her own dress on the red carpet and I
think every woman has to have that
happen and so embarrassing it was this
international stage and she felt
mortified
until this wouldn't and just kind of
reached down and took her out she's this
very tall woman just reach down helped
Kate out and said no don't worry about
it this happens to me all the time
that's no big deal come over here come
with us and so it was the first I mean I
know sweet is that a Tilda Swinton yeah
and then but then we immediately
confused her because she said so what
are you guys doing here and she's
Scottish but I don't have a very good
Scottish accent yeah yeah just like so
will you go soon here
you got it you got to hear my Milania
Trump's own mary did Donald Trump I
tells you yeah get away from McDonald so
she said well what are you doing here
are you premiering a film and and Kate
goes we're here for the emoji movie and
until sentences the emoji movie is it
screening it come and kids like no it's
just like well why are you here in
Kate's like he parasailed in and a
yellow tuxedo to premiere the trailer of
the emoji movie before the festival
started until it looks like well at
least he has weed you know because Kate
was like I know I'm married to a jackass
but we're having a lot of fun
you